- Relatively early in President
Trump's administration.
Mark Meadows and I,
this is before Mark
was Chief of Staff.
We're in the White House,
and we're visiting
someone in the West Wing
and one of the offices,
it may have been Jared's
office or somebody's office,
but they had a big
whiteboard on the wall.
And they had listed
every single promise
President Trump made
to the American people
in the 2016 campaign.
And they were just, I
mean, it was packed.
Get out of the Iran deal,
embassy in Jerusalem,
build the wall,
get out to Paris
Climate Accords,
conservatives on the court,
cut taxes, reduce regulation.
Just,
(whooshing)
it was packed, 'cause he made
a lot of important promises.
And they were checking 'em off.
Just literally checking them-
That's how you're
supposed to go.
- Yeah.
- What'd you tell the
people you're gonna do,
if they give you the
privilege of representing
and serving them,
and leading them?
Go do what you said.
And no one's done it better.
- I'm Dave Rubin
and we are in DC
(Jim laughs)
and joining me today, people
laugh just when you say DC.
Is the congressman for
Ohio's fourth district
who just won his
reelection by a landslide.
He also serves as
the ranking member
of the House Judiciary Committee
and is a co-founder of
the House Freedom Caucus.
Congressman Jim Jordan.
Good to see you my friend.
- Good to be with you.
Congratulations on all your
great work and success.
We appreciate what you do.
- Thank you.
Well, I'm just trying to
save the country like,
like some of us are trying-
- God bless you.
It's a great country, and
it's greatest country ever.
It's worth saving, it's
worth fighting for.
And, and so thank
you for doing that.
- Well, I appreciate that.
First off, I have to ask you,
why aren't your
sleeves rolled up?
- It should be-
- That's your trademark,
I've never seen-
- It's not as hot in DC
as it normally is here.
And so yeah, it's
sometimes though, in a
committee hearing when,
when that witness is
from the government
and you know they have
not been square with
the people I get to represent,
sometimes you gotta
roll up your sleeve
so you can really get after 'em
'cause they deserve it.
A lot of time, in my
judgment, a lot of times.
Like a Fauci guy, you know,
Fauci how many,
how many different,
how many things did Fauci
tells that we're not true?
- Pretty much everything.
- Yeah, exactly, see-
- Exactly.
Well you see the
piece in the, in the,
I think it was the Atlantic
like two weeks ago.
Let's all just-
- Oh, amnesty.
- Yeah. Like right.
Like let's just all get along
and not worry about the things
that said that, you know,
shut down the economy,
cost people their jobs.
Let people not go see their
mom or dad in a nursing home
and maybe they, they were on
their deathbed or so, I mean,
crazy stuff that
this guy did to us.
Oh, let's just all forget it.
And I'm not like, it's not
about holding a grudge,
it's about accountability
so it doesn't happen again.
And that guy,
anyway, I, I didn't even
mean to get started on that,
but you,
for some reason I thought
about it, like, what the heck?
- Well, alright, we can
get to some of that stuff,
but I have to ask,
the first thing I
have to ask you is
when I booked this trip to DC
we knew we were doing it
right after the election.
- Yeah.
- We thought the red
wave was a comin'
it's a trickle at best.
We still are unclear exactly
where the House is gonna end up.
Senate is not looking great.
We'll see what happens with
the Georgia thing, all that.
But, but clearly the
Republican party,
which I think should be doing
much better than it is, is,
is in this strange
state of flux.
What is going on here?
- Well, look,
the positive is I do think
we're gonna win the House.
It looks like 219,
220, maybe 221.
So, anything 218 or
up is, is win and,
and, and winning and
beats losing every time.
I learned that a long time ago.
So that's the positive.
But you're right. We thought
it was gonna be more,
I do think was,
I was talking with a,
a conservative reporter
who I have a great
deal of respect for
and she said that
we're gonna have to,
we're gonna have to do the
ballot harvesting the, the,
the mail in voting routine
as good as they do.
Because you know, we
won the popular vote.
- Yep.
50 some million to 47, whatever.
But it was like-
- I think it's about a
5 million difference-
- Yeah.
- Pro, for Republican
- 52, 47, something like that.
So, which is great.
And, and turnout was up
compared to 2018 midterm.
So something's
going right there.
But we lost so many close ones
in these states where there's
a huge mail in vote, it seems.
Like we lost all of them in,
the one incumbent
we kept in Nevada,
but we thought we could win
any of those three seats
and and Laxalt senate race.
We didn't win any of 'em.
So we're gonna have to do
something different there.
Washington State, Oregon,
California, Arizona.
These states where
there's such a mail in-
- But is it possible to do in-
well first off, do you wanna
do the exact same
tactics as them
because generally people on,
let's say our side don't
like these tactics, right?
We like to show up and vote
and feel that paper trail
and all of that.
- I know, I know.
- So that's, trust
me it was, I I,
I did it in Florida this time
where I had to show an
ID and a piece of paper.
It was a pleasure.
As opposed to Cali
where if you show an ID,
they'll basically
arrest you on the spot.
But so that there, do
you wanna really like,
like sort of philosophically
do we wanna do all the,
the shenanigans that they do?
That's number one.
And then number two,
can it be fixed in these places
that are so calcified blue?
What, what machinery can
actually go in there and fix it?
- Well it can't, like,
I mean you can't change the
law to something like in Ohio,
you're in Florida, we're in
Ohio, Ohio it's the same thing.
You walk in, show your ID,
there's two Democrats
setting there,
two Republicans show your ID.
Oh yeah, you're Jim Jordan,
there's a voter
registration thing.
Find your name,
flip it around you sign
it, signature match,
give you a ballot color in the,
the people you wanna vote for.
Paper trail in a machine.
Results.
- Exactly the same as
Florida. It was great.
- So we get our results
just like Florida,
we get 10:30 a night.
- Yeah.
- So, California's
not gonna change
'cause Democrats run everything
and they got super majorities
in their legislature.
So they're never
gonna change their law
to like what we have in, in
where it makes sense
in Florida and Ohio.
So I think you just sort
of have to, and I get it,
I did the same way I
vote on election date.
I think you're just
gonna have to say like
the rules have changed.
Like my background's wrestling.
If the rules change
in wrestling,
you gotta adapt to the rules.
Like okay,
take down's worth two,
if they're worth three,
and change what a reversal.
It's like, okay, we gotta, you
gotta readjust your strategy.
I think the same thing
applies here in those states.
And again, it's still gonna
be tough on, on Republicans,
because you know,
a lot of times Republican
voters are more rural voters.
So to show up at people's
homes is different
in rural Central
Valley of California
than it is in apartment
buildings in San Francisco
to to to to, you know,
take ballots of people
and, and get their votes.
So. But I think
we're gonna have to.
- What do we do about
that disconnect?
You know, when they show
you the map of the country,
right now the country
geographically is like 80% red,
and then of course you have
the big cities that are blue.
- Yeah.
- I don't think that disconnect
can hold forever because
people are, people are getting
really frustrated with that.
- Yeah.
- You know,
you live in the places
where they grow the food
and you're fighting
for resources
with the people in the big city.
- Right. Right.
It's, our chief of
staff has a great line,
he says, you know, west
central, north, central Ohio,
the, the, the great
district I get to represent,
we make things, grow
things, move things.
And I always tell, you know,
people on the coast,
who can work remote and,
and and you know,
sit at home in Northern Virginia
drinking their $15 cup of coffee
harassing the truck driver
and the manufacturer
and the small business
owner in Lima, Ohio.
Like, I, I get it.
And it and it is
frustrating, so.
And of course the mainstream
press is all the people-
- Yeah.
- You know, working remote,
you can't remote
work the crops in.
- Yeah.
- Right.
You gotta, you gotta go
out and plant the crops.
It's like, so it is
a frustrating thing.
I hope we can come together
at some point 'cause
it is so divisive.
It's like we had
this huge election,
millions and millions
and millions of dollars,
maybe billions of dollars
spent, probably was billion.
'Cause McCarthy,
Kevin raised like,
I think he raised like half
a million himself, and from,
so billions spent
and we basically,
looks like we're gonna
almost be status quo.
We're gonna get the
House, but, Senate,
it's gonna maybe even go down.
I think Herschel's
gonna win in Georgia,
but we, so we're gonna
be the same result.
- Are are you okay with the,
the splitting of the
states in that, you know,
I saw something just
the other morning that
it's something like
in the last three years
about 500,000 people
have left New York.
Now a huge percentage of
them end up in Florida.
They vote red, Florida
becomes more red.
And then unfortunately New
York becomes more blue.
Kathy Hochul only won New
York by about 330,000 votes.
Those people stay.
- Yeah. Lee Zeldin's governor.
- But, right.
And we get Lee Zeldin who
I think has a huge future.
- That guy.
- I yeah, what do
you think about him?
Because he did something that
pretty much nobody
thought could be done.
And very few people knew
who he was a month ago.
- I got to know Lee during
the first impeachment.
There were four of us who,
who were in almost
every deposition.
We were actually
down in the bunker
in the basement of the capital,
I think more than
Adam Schiff was,
'cause it was, it was
Scott Perry, Mark Meadows,
Lee and myself.
And then our, our
our staff lawyers,
Steve Castor and our team.
Lee's a good man, smart guy.
And, and again, this
is the other thing
I think is important.
He was a, a good
disciplined candidate
about talking about the things
New Yorkers cared about.
And I would argue his,
his intense and, and, and
quality race that he ran is,
is a big reason why we picked
up so many seats in New York.
- I think New York
flipped four seats.
- Right, right.
And, and so, you know,
we we, we tweeted out,
God bless Lee Zeldin after we,
we started winning a bunch
of those New York seats.
Yeah. I think he's got a
bright future in our party
and is a good man
with a good family.
And what he went through in
that campaign, God bless him.
It's tough. I mean.
- Literally attacked on stage.
- Literally attacked.
- But, but what do you
think about the states
kind of going their, their
separate ways in in some sense?
- Well I think it's-
- It's happening.
- No, it's, it's Americans.
Americans. But you know, 'cause
remember our, remember our,
it's in our DNA.
When, when, when,
when we started this
place over in Europe,
they said you gotta practice
your faith a certain way.
And they said, no, we don't.
By golly we're
gonna get on a ship,
risk it all, go to this
place where, you know,
we call America, and
we're gonna do it the way
we think the good
Lord wants us to.
And we're gonna have
our goals in our dreams
and we're gonna make 'em happen.
And, and people in New York
where they we're getting,
they're being attacked and
on all kinds of things.
And all the left like,
well forget this noise.
I'm gonna go to Florida,
I'm gonna go to Texas,
I'm gonna go to Nashville,
I'm going to Tennessee.
So yeah, you see that happening.
You can't blame Americans.
'Cause like I said,
I think that's kind of in our,
kind of in our DNA
to, to some degree.
- Yeah.
- They, we, we
naturally crave freedom
and they're going places where
you can experience freedom.
- Yeah. Are you-
- But it is, does make
me concerned because
it's tough then to ever win.
Are we ever gonna
get California back?
It's probably gonna
take a whole generation,
and maybe it's gonna get,
it's sad to see, but maybe,
maybe when it gets even
worse in these places,
maybe then people see the
light and say, okay, time out.
We just can't take it anymore.
And we started to thought
that was gonna happen Tuesday.
And it did to a little,
to a smaller degree.
- I think I've asked
every Republican
that I've had on the show this,
so I've probably asked
you this question
at least once or twice before,
but when you talk to your
Democrat counterparts,
do they honestly believe
that the policies they're
implementing are working?
Or do they just
believe, you know,
the the sort of
cynical view would be
that they just believe
it's keeping them in power
'cause they're giving people
stuff, and, it's working.
- I think the ones who are
still sort of open minded
and not just totally
left wing radicals,
I think they, they think
like, yeah, this is,
well even Maloney said this
week that, you know, that the,
after he lost his
race in New York, he,
I think I saw where he said
something like
this whole defund the
police movement is crazy.
You know.
Well we haven't heard a
Democrat say that for,
for three years,
but he finally did
and he happened to be the, the,
the guy running the
Democrat campaign apparatus.
So, I think deep down,
some of 'em know it.
But remember the left
controls that party.
- Yeah.
- The left controls that party.
And there was a survey
done two months ago,
Democrats asking Democrats,
and 55% of Democrats said,
they do not think America's
the greatest nation ever.
That's frightening.
You got a majority
of one of the two
major political
parties in this country
that doesn't believe what
you and I know to be fact,
greatest country.
I've traveled, I've been to,
I wrestled in the Soviet Union.
I was, I went to
Cuba in 1988, 1990.
You go to places like that,
you thank the good
Lord you live here.
- Everyone still
wants to come here.
Nobody's leaving,
nobody's leaving.
- So that's that, that,
that's the control,
that's the power in their party.
And a bunch of the folks in
Congress buy into that idea
that America's somehow, I mean,
America's the
greatest country ever.
It's not perfect, but
it's the greatest.
And they just don't
see it that way.
- Do you, do you think that
that just got strengthened
within their party
because they didn't really
suffer any massive setbacks?
So now it's like, well
we can kind of keep going
with that stuff. Right?
- Joe Biden said it. Joe Biden
said, what are you changing?
Nothing. What
didn't, nothing like?
Okay, so you want,
you want the people,
you're supposed to be
leading and representing,
the American people.
You want them to continue
to pay $5 for gas?
You want them to continue to pay
a 41 year high inflation rate?
You want them to continue
to have crime everywhere?
You wanna continue
to have a border
that's no longer a border?
I mean, really?
You wanna continue to see
the Constitution attacked
by your Justice Department?
- But that's what I mean
about the cynical version
that's not very cynical.
I think they're looking at
all that and going, man,
these people must
be idiots because
they keep voting for us,
or, or whatever they're doing
with the harvesting
and everything else.
- Yeah.
- There's been no,
no price to pay.
- They, they,
they're, I mean, yes.
I wish, they're
gonna lose the house.
They're gonna lose the house.
I'm, I'm confident
of that today.
- So what are you guys gonna do?
Let's, let's get into
some of that quick, okay,
so you get the house now,
maybe you can do some
hearings about some things.
You've led the charge on a
lot of the big tech stuff.
It sort of feels like a lot
of that is now in the past,
that people aren't
been thinking of it
as an issue anymore maybe.
And maybe in a good sense
in that Elon's now come in,
Twitter feels like
it'll be a little fair.
- Helpful. Definitely helpful.
- So that's good.
But but does anything come
of these hearings beyond the,
the moments, you know,
you nail someone, or Rand
Paul nails Fauci on this?
Does-
- And it shouldn't
be about that.
It should be about the facts.
- Yeah.
- It should be about
the American people.
Part of our constitutional duty.
We take the oath of
office on January 3rd.
Part of our duty is to get the,
do oversight so the
country knows the truth.
They deserve that.
So I'm committed to doing
that in an aggressive way.
And I think when you do that,
hopefully,
it begins to slow down
some of these agencies
and the things they're doing
that I think are
just flat out wrong.
And again, we've seen some
unprecedented things happen.
14 whistleblowers
come talk to us.
We issue a thousand page
report a week and a half ago.
That thousand page report
highlights how political
the place has become,
the Justice Department.
One FBI agent, and again,
he's, he's talking about
not the rank and file,
but the people at the
Washington Field office.
One FBI agent who
came to us as a,
as a whistleblower said
the FBI at its at its top,
at the Washington Field office
at its leadership level,
rotted to the
core. Direct quote.
I mean, you got an agent,
who's given his
life to this agency
saying it's rotted to the
court at its leadership level
that should tell us something.
So, and then the
negative reaction we got
from the mainstream press
on this report tells
us we're, I mean,
it's always a good sign when,
when the Washington
Post is attacking you,
that's usually a good thing.
- What do you make of this
report that was leaked
about how the
administration for sure,
or at least the intelligence
services for sure,
were working with big
tech to silence people.
I mean, we, they admitted
it, Psaki admitted it.
Remember we flag posts for
Facebook, but now they're like,
we have the evidence.
But the question is,
and I think everyone
wants, oh wait, okay,
well is anything gonna happen?
- Yeah. And I get that
question and it's, I mean,
if it's frustrating
for you and I,
who follow this stuff,
imagine just American citizens
who are busy running
their business
and volunteering at church
and going to Little League
and soccer games and,
imagine what it's like for them.
So that is frustrating
to all of us.
I always point
out to 'em though,
all we can do is get the facts
out there. At some point.
You gotta have,
have you got to have
a Justice Department
that's willing to
prosecute people for,
if you got the government
actively pressuring press.
Pressuring these,
these social media platforms
to restrict information
and they're doing it
for purely partisan
political advantage,
that is a total violation
of the First Amendment.
- Yeah.
- Totally wrong.
And those people should
be held accountable.
But I don't know that this
Justice Department will do it.
- Right.
You may remember I had
a tweet in July of 2021
saying that vaccine
mandates were coming,
the vaccines aren't
working as promised.
And in essence, we should
pause and think about it.
And I got banned.
And the question from
Twitter question-
(indistinct chatter)
The question is,
was that pressure that someone
in in the administration,
or-
- Did Fauci get on
the phone and call?
- Which is then a
direct violation
of my first amendment rights.
- I assume with the
time, maybe he was, he,
maybe he already left, but
whoever did he call Twitter?
Did he call Zuckerberg? I
mean, we know Fauci was texting
and, and and emailing
with, with Zuckerberg.
So yeah.
Or someone else.
I mean remember to, to,
you mentioned Jen Psaki.
I, I'm watching,
so Jen Psaki in the
White House press room.
This is, this is, I don't
know, six, eight months ago,
Jen Psaki.
Now think about the White
House is the center of freedom
for consider,
like the beacon of freedom
on the in the world.
And you're in the White House
in the press room
in the West Wing
and the press spokesperson
for the President of the
United States, Jen Psaki
standing at the podium
in the press room,
and she says, most
Americans get their news
from social media platforms.
We're working with us
social media platforms
to understand and limit
what Americans see.
And I literally saw that
live and I'm like, what?
You're the press person talking
about limiting the press
from the press room
in the White House?
Like, what-
- But again, there's
no price to pay
and she just gets a six
figure deal at MSNBC.
- This big shot at, at MSNBC.
So-
- All right, we only got
about three minutes left.
So I'm gonna ask
you the big one,
which I'm sure is the one
that you don't want to
talk about, probably.
But last time I had you on,
you said that you absolutely
would support Donald Trump
if he runs, we're taping
this on, on Monday.
It sounds like
he might make some sort
of announcement tomorrow.
But you can already feel
what's really going on here,
which is that the entire
machine wants to set this up
as some sort of Trump
DeSantis, you know,
battle royal and then just
destroy everybody kind of thing.
What do you make of what the
future of the party will be?
And is there a way to do
a fight out in the open
that, that leaves Republicans
kind of okay at the end,
if, if DeSantis
even wants to run.
I, I don't know.
- I look, I'm, I'm
for President Trump,
I think he's the best
president we've, we've had,
and certainly my
lifetime, maybe ever,
just did more what he
said he was gonna do than,
than any president
I've ever seen.
And he did it with everyone
in this town against him.
Every Democrat, everyone in
the mainstream press, every,
you know, half the Republicans,
and all the bureaucracy.
And in spite of that, got
more done than, you know.
And I used to just
go down there.
There's an amazing
list of things.
- Yeah, no.
- So I'm for President Trump.
I think he's the
leader of our party.
I want him to run again.
The speech he gave Monday
night before the election
in, in our state.
- Yeah.
- Unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
What a leader.
So I, I'm for him.
- Yeah.
But Ron DeSantis,
look, there was,
there were nine of us who
formed the Freedom Caucus
seven years ago.
Ron was one of
the original nine.
And he's done a great
job as governor. But-
- It, do you think there's
a way to have it out
with the two of them
without really irreparably
damaging somebody?
Because policy-wise
they're both nailing it.
But that, that means
it's gonna have to
get to something
else that's gonna be
pretty dirty, probably.
- Look, I, I, I, I hope,
I hope it's President Trump,
and I'd prefer he Ron, you know,
keep running Florida and then-
- Listen, I love Florida.
I feel like I'm gonna
win either way here, but-
- And then run for president.
He's got plenty of
time. But, but that,
that'll be his decision.
But no matter what I'm gonna
be for President Trump,
I think he was the kind of
leader that, that we need.
And if there's a
competition, then, you know,
we're the party of competition.
Voters will decide.
And, and you know,
God bless America.
I, I always, you
know, like I said,
my background's wrestling.
You gotta win the semifinals
before you get to
wrestle in the finals.
That's the way the
tournament goes.
And, but I think, I think I,
I still remember,
this is early,
relatively early in President
Trump's administration.
Mark Meadows and I, this is
before Mark was chief of staff.
We're in the White House,
and we're visiting
someone in the
West Wing and one
of the offices,
it may have been Jared's
office or somebody's office,
but they had a big
whiteboard on the wall,
and they had listed
every single promise
President Trump made
to the American people
in the 2016 campaign.
And they were just, I
mean, it was packed.
Get outta the Iran deal,
embassy in Jerusalem,
build the wall, get outta
the Paris Climate Accords,
conservatives on the court,
cut taxes, reduce regulation,
just,
(whooshing)
it was packed,
'cause he made a lot
of important promises
and they were checking 'em off,
just literally checking-
That's how you're
supposed to go.
- Yeah.
- What'd you tell the
people you're gonna do
if they give you the
privilege of representing
and serving them
and leading them?
Go do what you said, and
no one's done it better.
And and then people say,
well, yeah, but you know,
some of the things,
I think that toughness is,
is the only attitude that
can work in this town.
When you look at how bad
the mainstream press is,
how mean the Left is how,
how vicious the
cancel culture is.
You've gotta have
someone as tough as Trump
to deal with all that.
That's why I'm for him.
- It's funny, I used to always,
people would always say,
you know, well I, I like him,
but you know, the tweets.
The tweets. And I
would always say, well,
you can't tell the guy
who did the thing that no
one said could be done,
that he has to act a little
more like you would act.
- Yeah.
- Because most likely you
didn't accomplish that.
- You probably said this too,
I don't know I'd have
to go back and look,
but my guess is you're
like some of our,
some of the smart political
people, we have that,
that worked with us.
I don't think anyone else
could have beat Hillary
Clinton in 2016.
- No, for sure, of course.
- He was the only one
that could have done it.
The only one that
could have done it.
And imagine we had her there,
we'd have had the same thing
we had on Biden for two years.
We've been living under
that for four years.
For goodness sake.
- Look, the simple truth is,
no matter whether
he runs or not or
becomes president again
or not, or whatever, like,
we owe the guy a massive
debt of gratitude.
All of the truth that
we're now seeing-
- Yes.
- Whether we can do
anything with it or not.
- Yeah.
- It, it is in large
part because of him.
It's in large part
because of you.
Thank you my friend.
- It's been cause of you.
Thanks for what you're doing.
- Roll up those sleeves.
It's, you're freaking
me out with the-
- Here we go for the last,
for the last two seconds.
Right. Last two seconds.
- Jim Jordan
rolling his sleeves.
Awesome. Thank you.
Yeah.
If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.